in the last video we saw that a system
could do work by expanding in this in
the situation we drew we had the
situation where the ceiling was movable
we had this piston and we like in our in
our quasi-static process video we had a
bunch of pebbles we removed a pebble so
the pressure in our system if we assume
that it was just so small that the
pressure was constant it pushed up on
the piston with some force we figured
out that that force since pressure is
force per area we just multiply pressure
times the area
of our piston and we got the amount of
force we're applying we apply that and
then we multiply that times the distance
that we push the piston up and then we
get the we get the amount of work that
it did by expansion or the expansion
work we said well you know we could have
rewritten that if we said pressure
times our area times our distance we
could instead write that as pressure
times the area times the distance and
the area times the distance is the
change in volume and so we came up with
a neat little formulation that the work
done by a system could be written as the
pressure times the change in volume so
in this case i wrote the internal energy
formula where it's the work done by the
system so i did a minus right because
when you do work you are giving energy
away to someone else
so in that situation we did a minus and
so we could instead of writing work we
could say minus the pressure times the
change in volume and remember this is a
quasi-static process we're doing it very
small increments we're assuming that
this change in volume is very small and
that the pressure is roughly constant
while we're doing this and of course
that's not the case right if we did this
if this was a large change in volume or
if this happened all of a sudden if
these were really big pebbles then our
pressure will change as we expand so
it's hard to say what the pressure times
the change in volume is but if we assume
things are really really being done in a
very very small increments we can say
okay let's say the pressure was constant
over that small increment and then we
can multiply it by the change in volume
now let's see how this can relate to
some of what we've done before with the
pv diagram and so far
all we've seen the pv diagram or what i
used it for is to kind of help explain
the difference between
quasi-static processes or to say when
macro states are defined
but let me now do something more useful
with it and this will give you an idea
or start giving you an idea of why
people who study thermodynamics love
these so much so before i did anything
when my canister was just here i had all
the pebbles on them we were in a state
of equilibrium i could describe all of
its macro states its pressure its volume
its temperature including it i could
describe its internal energy as well
but let me draw it here so let's say i
was at this state this was state number
one
state number one
was right there
and then let's say i just start removing
pebbles remember if i just removed all
the pebbles at once the system is going
to go into flux we wouldn't be doing a
quasi-static process or a reversible
process which isn't always the same
thing but for our purposes we wouldn't
we wouldn't be in equilibrium the whole
time and we'd have to wait to get to
equilibrium and at some point we'd have
some pressure and volume that's down
here this is if we weren't doing it as a
quasi-static process
now we are what i showed in the last
video we are doing it as a or we're
trying to get close to a quasi-static
process because we're doing it in small
increments in these little pebbles and
if these aren't small enough for you
could do it in smaller pebbles so we're
moving incrementally so for example in
that last video we maybe moved from
there we removed one pebble and we got
right there you remove another pebble
you go right there you move another
pebble you go right there and the
benefit of doing these quasi-static
processes is you really get a path going
from one state to the next so if your
move if let's say when you remove all
but one of the pebbles just you know
this describes our path so let's say we
are in state two and we've removed all
but one let me draw that
so state two
will look something like this i'll draw
it really quick
so that's our container
that's our piston we only have one
pebble left on top
and then of course we have the gas
now the gas we have a much higher this
is let me write this down this is state
two and let me write state one was
something like this
state one
the ceiling was lower we had a bunch of
pebbles on top of it
on top of it
and we had a smaller volume and so the
gas was bumping into the ceilings
and the walls and the floor a lot more i
should draw the same number so we had a
higher pressure so pressure was high
pressure high
and volume low
now in state two so this is pressure
high so this is pressure is this axis
this is pr x is volume so we had high
pressure low volume and we got this
situation after removing all but one
pebble we're and we're doing it slowly
so we're always in equilibrium so we
have a path this is after removing each
of the pebbles so that our pressure and
volume macro states are always well
defined but at state two we now have a
pressure low
and
volume is high
the volume is high you can see that
because we kept pushing the piston up
slowly slowly trying to maintain
ourselves in equilibrium so our macro
states are always defined and our
pressure is lower just because we're
going to be we could have the same
number of particles but they're just
going to bump into the walls a little
bit less because they have a little bit
more room to to move around and that's
all fair and dandy so this describes the
path of the of our of our system as it
transitioned or as it experienced this
process which was a a quasi-static
process so everything was defined at
every point now we said that the work
done at any given point by the system is
the pressure times the change in volume
now how does that relate to here change
in volume is just a certain distance
along this x-axis
along or like i should call the volume
axis this is a change in volume
right we started off at this volume and
let's say we removed one pebble we got
to this volume
now we want to multiply that diagonal as
our pressure since we did it over such a
small increment and we're over we're so
close to equilibrium we can assume that
our pressure is roughly constant over
that period of time so we could say that
this is the pressure over that period of
time
and so how much work we did it's this
pressure
over here
times this volume
which is the area of this rectangle the
area of this rectangle right there
and for any of y'all who've seen my
calculus videos this should start
looking a little bit familiar
right
and then what what about when we take
our next pebble well now our pressure is
a little bit lower this is our new
pressure
our pressure is a little bit lower
and we multiply that times our new
change in volume
times this change in volume and we have
that increment of work
once again is the is the area of this
rectangle and if you keep doing that the
amount of work
we do is essentially the area
of all of these rectangles as we remove
each pebble and now you might say
especially those of you who haven't
watched my calculus videos g
you know this might be getting close but
these the area of these rectangles isn't
exactly there this curve there's you
know it's a little inexact there's a
little error here and what i would say
is well if you if you're worried about
that what you should do is
use smaller increments of volume and if
you want to have smaller changes in
volume along each step what you do is
you remove even smaller pebbles and this
goes back to trying to get to that ideal
quasi-static process so if you did that
eventually the rectangle the delta v's
would get smaller and smaller and
smaller and the rectangles would get
thinner and thinner thinner you'd have
to do it over more and more steps but
eventually you'll get to a point if you
assume really small changes in delta in
in in our delta v and calculus world
that infinitely small changes you write
it as dv
so if you if you take a sum of all the
pressures times the dvs you get the area
under this curve
so the way to think about it when you're
looking at this pv diagram if someone
says you're going from this point this
pressure in this volume to this pressure
in this volume and they say how much
work did you did you say okay well i
just have to figure out the area under
this curve if you wanted to know the
real math behind it if you could get
your pressure as a function of volume
and if you don't know any if you haven't
watched the calculus videos you can
ignore this little decide i'm going to
do here but essentially this is this
curve right here
you could if you could write it this way
let's say you could write pressure as a
function of volume
right and and when you're in in algebra
you learn a curve as a you know y is a
function of x but here y is the pressure
and x is volume so it's pressure as a
function of volume so the area under
this curve
is the integral
of the pressure as a function of volume
that's the height at any point
right
times our very small change in volume
so times are our
very small change in volume and you take
the sum from our our starting volume so
volume
initial to volume final and we'll do
this in the future when we actually
especially when we start touching on
entropy but this is a neat result if
even if you don't know the calculus or
if this confuses you if you've never
seen an integral before you could ignore
it but you could look at this
intuitively you say the work i did is
the area under this curve
now let me ask you one more thing let's
say some work is being done to the
system so we start adding some marbles
back
right
so let's say actually let's say we're
going from this direction let's say we
start at state 2 and we go in that
direction so direction matters
so let's say we go in that direction
right there so i should put some arrows
and i'm overloading this picture so much
actually let me just do a new picture
that's probably the best thing to do
so it's pressure
volume i'm actually going to do two
nope
let me just do
pressure
volume i'm going to do two graphs here
all right so in the first one is
pressure volume pressure volume we
started here at one and we went here to
two
so our system was essentially pushed up
on the piston and it could be a curve or
a line i'm not going to get too
particular right now but it was going in
this direction
and so we can say that the work done was
the pressure times the increase in
volume at any moment so the work done
was the area under this curve
the work done was the area under that
curve
now if we started at position two
if we started at position two and we go
to position one two to one
now what's happening now we're
compressing so if we're going in that
direction
you might say okay maybe the work done
by the system is still the area under
the curve well you'd be close because
what's happening now working out
compressing the system we're adding the
marbles back we're putting energy into
the system so if we do that remember
your work done by the system was
pressure times an increase in volume
now it's going to be your pressure times
a decrease in volume so when you go back
in this direction when you go back in
this direction the area is not the work
done by the system it's the area it's
the work done to the system maybe i'll
do that in a different color so blue for
or green for work done to the system
now let me throw you another little
interesting idea and this is actually a
key idea
it's good to get the intuition here so
let me just draw a very simple pv
diagram again
nope
use the wrong tool
let me use another pv so let's say we
start at some state here
state one and i do i do something
you know i i'm in a quasi-static process
and it you know it's doing something
weird and i get to state 2 here
i get to state 2 here and it's going in
this direction
right so my volume is increasing so in
this situation what is the work done by
the system easy enough it's the area
under this curve
it's the area under this curve
now let's say that i i keep doing some
type of
i do some type of
quasi-static process but it takes a
different path i'm doing something else
other than adding the marbles directly
back so my new path looks something like
this
my new path looks something like
this to get back to state one
to get back to state one
so these arrows are going back so now
what is the work done to the system well
my volume is decreasing so it's the area
under the second curve
the area under the second curve is the
work done to the system
so if i want to know what the net work
the system did going from state 1 to
state 2 and then going back to state 1.
remember this is a pressure and volume
diagram what is it well the work that
the system did was this whole area under
this brown curve and then it had some
work done to it which is the the area
under this magenta curve so the net work
it did
is essentially the white the whole area
minus this red area so the network it
did would be
essentially just the area inside this
loop
the area inside that loop and hopefully
you don't have to know calculus to do
this although calculus you would
actually use to compute
to actually compute these areas but i
just want to give you that intuition
that the the area inside this closed
loop is actually the amount of work that
our system has done when it's going and
what's important is that the direction
that it's going so it increased volume
then decreased volume so it's kind of
this this clockwise motion this is the
work that our system has done
which i don't know to me is a pretty
interesting thing and later we can use
this notion to come up with some other
ideas behind our state variables
i'll make one little aside here remember
our state our state variable pressure
volume we did stuff to it that we went
back to that state that stayed the same
and i want to say another thing for our
purposes when we're dealing with ideal
gases
where the internal energy is essentially
the kinetic energy of the system if we
go and do all sorts of crazy stuff and
come back
our internal energy hasn't changed so
the internal energy is always going to
be the same at this point so if i said i
did all of this stuff and came back here
what is my change in internal energy
it's zero change is zero now if i said i
went from here to here i would have a
different internal energy and my change
would be something real but since this
is a state function it doesn't care how
i got there if i took all these loops
and got back there just says look if i'm
at this point in the pv diagram
my internal energy is the same thing so
if i get if i start at this point and i
finish again at this point
i have had no change in internal energy
and we'll talk more about that in the
next video but i just wanted to leave
you there and get you this intuition
behind the areas under the curves in the
pv diagram